I know you're going to be blown away by
this but we're going to have to talk
about free speech today it would be nice
if a week would pass when there wasn't
some sort of threat to freedom of speech
but it seems that almost every day
there's a new outrage on the horizon
aimed at chipping away our right to free
expression there are three specific
happenings right now that I want to
focus on in no particular order first
there's the ongoing saga of Brett
Weinstein at Evergreen University in
Washington in case you missed our live
stream with Brett last week he's being
attacked by being called a racist and a
bigot for opposing a day in which white
students wouldn't be welcome on campus
Brett claimed that the revised day of
absence on campus based on racial
segregation was not just racist and
bigoted but was the complete reverse of
what the day was supposed to stand for
Brett has been a progressive and afar
lefty his whole life but even he is not
immune to the toxic ideology of leftism
which rates victimhood as virtue and
will swallow anyone who dares deviate
from its authoritarian rule the campus
was closed for a couple days due to
threats of violence and even now Brett
is getting no backing from the
administration which appears to be
bending to the demands of the crazed mob
even worse mainstream media is basically
all but ignoring this story because it's
so shatters the regressive ideology
mainstream left-leaning
outlets don't want to touch this story
because they don't want to be tarred the
same way Brett has been thus almost all
the coverage of the Evergreen story has
been from right-leaning websites Brett
isms three live interviews that I know
of one right here one on Joe Rogan's
podcast and one with Tucker Carlson on
Fox News he hasn't been invited on CNN
or MSNBC or NPR and none of those
outlets have even written a piece on the
story when you hear the trust in
mainstream media is at an all-time low
it's reasons like ignoring hugely
relevant stories that go against their
narrative that are part of the reason
the next story of the last few days
is was the outrage over Kathy Griffin's
isis-inspired photos holding up
president Trump's decapitated bloody
head first off on the free speech front
I fully support Kathy's right to take
these pictures and make art as she sees
fit I don't think that these photos are
a direct call to violence which would be
a crime and the pictures should be seen
through the lens that she's a comedian
and a provocateur regardless of whether
you think the images are in poor taste
or just outright awful so while it is a
hundred percent in her right to make the
images it's also a hundred percent in
CNN's right as her employer to fire her
if they see fit now interestingly in
this case it was the right calling for
CNN to fire Griffin and it was a less
that was defending her although they
were doing it a bit less than usual
while this is a flip on the script of
the last few years it's important to
remember it seems people only hold their
values when it's easy to do so just
imagine if it had been a conservative
comedian like Tim Allen holding up a
severed head of President Obama the left
would have been demanding his show be
canceled and the right would have been
defending him ironically Tim Allen's
highly rated show was canceled a couple
weeks ago and many people think that it
is at least partially because he's been
an outspoken conservative in Hollywood
the final story I want to touch on is
the outrage over Bill Maher using the
n-word on real time last Friday I can't
even repeat what Bill Maher said because
even just by quoting him I'll end up in
hot water which shows you just how
insane the language police have got
basically he made a joke using the
n-word and all hell broke loose to be
clear if you didn't use the N word to
describe anyone in particular or take a
racist position it was a line that I
suspect was prepackaged to elicit a
reaction from the crowd it not only did
elicit a reaction from the live studio
audience but also the bigoted ear
Brigade which immediately began calling
for his firing from HBO I even saw
comedians that I know calling for him to
be fired over a joke this is Bill Maher
who many of you who lean right
absolutely hate and now the left is
doing your job of trying to destroy him
sadly the left has been come
for Bill for a long time mainly because
he isn't afraid of talking about radical
Islam which has set him apart from most
on the Left I know a little thing about
that myself
HBO took the joke out of repeats of the
program and so far has withstood calls
to fire him and Maher even apologized
something he's chastised others for
doing in the past senator Al Franken
canceled an appearance on real time for
this week despite being a friend of Bill
and of the show for many years I've
invited senator Franken on the show to
discuss but I'm not going to hold my
breath so there you have it a professor
bullied off campus by threats of
violence for fighting against racism a
comedian fired for a tasteless gag and
another comic under the threat of firing
for a joke none of these are threats to
the First Amendment which of course as
you know is the government coming for
your speech but they all add up to the
chill factor around freedom of
expression that I've been talking about
for quite some time if you are a
professor would you be willing to
explore a controversial idea with
students after what's happened to Brett
if you were an artist would you be
willing to paint a controversial
painting after what's happened to Kathy
and if you were a comic would you be
willing to tell an offensive joke after
what's happening to Bill if you answered
no to any of those then you must
acknowledge that the threat to free
expression is real don't like Brett
don't take his class think Kathy is
crass watch something else on new years
don't think bill is funny change the
channel but whatever you do keep
watching the Rubin report because we've
got Jason Whitlock from Fox Sports one
on the show this week he was in his own
outrage Appaloosa
last week with the course calls for him
to be fired - but I'll save that for our
chat
[Music]
joining me today is the co-host of speak
for yourself on foxsports1 and a man who
has no problem speaking for himself
Jason Whitlock welcome to the Reuben
report glad to be here I wanted to be
here
the expand of yours babe I love what
you're doing Thanks well I feel the same
way we had a strange interaction on dm's
on twitter where i invited you on the
show not understanding that you actually
do live in LA you're here we could have
had your months ago but your timing is
good because at the top of the show I
was talking about people getting in
trouble for speech and this is something
you've consistently managed to do yeah I
think anybody that particularly now
previously it used to be celebrated in
the media but now it's pretty much
derided anytime you say anything that
doesn't go along with groupthink
people over social media get irate and
I've seen my entire industry I'm someone
that still considers myself a journalist
although I'm doing broadcasting now but
I was a big fan I grew up idolizing Mike
Rowe at the Chicago Tribune and he
became a pillar surprise winner became
very successful in this industry because
you could not predict his position and
he just came across dishonest and fair
and whether you liked him or not as a
position it came from a real place and
I've seen this industry if Mike Royko
were alive today he would not be
successful
yeah you have to be populist
and preached to acquire to be successful
in this industry isn't that kind of
crazy considering that you're in the
sports industry now I know you talk a
lot about politics I are going to get
into a lot of your opinions on things
but you're in the sports biz which you
should be allowed to say what you want
because you're not you find like you're
dealing with abortion on a day to day
basis or gun control er things although
a lot of these things have now seeped
into the sport conversation but when you
started this did you ever think that you
were going to end up stuck in this place
of you know not you're never afraid to
say what you think but stuck in this
place where that would be an issue
I'm totally shocked because again my
goal getting in this business was oh I
want to be the microwave sports and I
just well that'll be great
hahahaha and that'll make me popular and
people will respect the fact that my
positions are unpredictable or they're
not tied to an agenda so yeah I'm
completely surprised that this is where
we've landed in American media where
again original thoughts are thoughts
that really challenge the establishment
are derided and are you know people are
social media is trying to silence it's
funny because the being against the
establishment is supposed to be the cool
thing right about George Carlin that's
that's quite the power that's that's the
history of America is by power and
somehow now that's become not cool in a
bizarre way well well depending on which
way you look at it that the resistant
the hashtag resistant people think it's
cool at the moment yeah but I don't know
if that's actually the power right and I
here's what get me in trouble the
resistance movement is actually an
establishment movement and they think
they're being anti-establishment but
Donald Trump is not the established
because that's what I was getting here
he is actually burning down the
establishment and the entire and again
I'm a this isn't me taping up for Trump
but the entire resistance movement is
actually the establishment fighting back
against people that are trying to tear
down their cells yeah so let's unpack
that a little bit for the people that
don't get it because I feel the same way
that he's not yes he is the president
but he's not the full establishment when
you talk about the media and Hollywood
and the groupthink the things that were
allowed to say that's really the power
he's the one that taken the hatchet to
that right again whether you support him
or not without question and the other
thing to label Donald Trump is any type
of classic conservative is preposterous
he's not a conservative uh you know he's
a blowhard
that was a good TV personality a
successful TV personality obviously a
successful real estate
person but mostly a blowhard and you
know he doesn't represent any particular
political agenda other than uh you know
he may be the genders real estate
billionaires or everyone I'm not sure
girls must be on that yeah are you a
conservative do you consider yourself a
conservative I mean I know sort of what
your politics are mostly through Twitter
in the show but I just kidding I don't
want to reject the conservative label
yeah uh but you know I've written for
The Huffington Post uh you know I'm anti
guns
I think the Second Amendment is a farce
in 2017 so you would scrap it all
together you have the Second Amendment
to joke really in my view I think that
uh you know the right to bear arms and
have a militia to protect yourself
against the government at all I think
made sense back when the Constitution
was written but unless we're all going
to have access to drones
we really can't protect I guess the
government yeah I don't have any stealth
bomb or anything but how do you
reconcile that is someone that obviously
is a healthy distrust of power uh yeah I
just think guns are unhealthy I think
that gun by I'm an African American and
when you look at the statistics about
who gun violence really impacts its us
and so you know III just looked at the
stats and say you own a gun in your home
you're more likely to shoot a family
member friend a loved one then you are
an intruder and again I get why people
like to hunt
I'm not against hunting and guns for
that reason but all the handguns that
are proliferated and all the
semi-automatic weapons and all the stuff
people are buying up preparing for the
end of the United States of America yeah
if the government decides they want to
take us out build wrong tanks Delta's
into submission and our guns won't mean
anything it's a lost battle anyway with
our muskets versa
ever since they're grown you've talked a
bunch about guns and the controversy
that it has in the black community do
you think and but I but what I find
interesting is that you do lay out some
numbers I've heard you talk about the
numbers of amount a black on black crime
and all that stuff you get a lot of
pushback on that right yeah I just think
that as an african-american and keep in
mind Dave I lost a loved one
that I was close to that I helped raise
spend a lot of summers with me it was a
cousin his mom was like a sister to me
growing up names Anton Butler he was
killed and me and my families of you
because of police misconduct he was
tasered to death in the rain unarmed and
so again the police have a different
narrative and you can go look it up at
this happen Indianapolis in 2012 I've
been touched by police misconduct paid
for the funeral shed the tears but I
don't believe my cousin
got in that position because the police
are out just to do indiscriminate harm
to black people I believe he got in that
position because of America's drug war
and mass incarceration policy and he was
a felon through his involvement with
drugs and that that vulnerability of
being a felon who had done time put him
in a place where he could be subject to
police misconduct but it is police
misconduct our real issue as
african-americans no it's not
the government is already highly
motivated to stop police misconduct
because it's highly expensive when the
police kill someone harms someone there
are lawsuits and there are settlements
with the family and the government does
not want to do that what the government
wants done is for poor people regardless
of color but poor people escorted
politely to jail if you escort them
politely to jail you can turn a buck on
them you can make a profit
is an industrial complex can eat off of
politely escorting people to prison they
don't want the police and there's all
kinds of things set up to prevent the
police from harming people and they do
it very rarely social media has
convinced us that this is that the
police are just randomly out killing
people and it's just not true so I saw a
video that you did about the social
media component is that it that it
confuses what the actual stats are what
the actual issues are things like that
you call them Seibert with a cyber cyber
human cyber human so tell you a little
bit about cyber is because I talk about
this idea I to that that online thing is
starting to leak into the real world
it's not even it's not leaked it's there
is that the media we're addicted to
social media we're addicted to Twitter
if you go look at the stat the
overwhelming majority of Americans have
nothing to do with Twitter nothing it's
not a representation of what people
actually think in American society the
media over indexes celebrities over
index athletes people that are trying to
build brands or and people that are
attracted to people that are trying to
fill brands are the people that are on
social media and so because of the media
overindulge is a social medium because
we use it as wet our fingers all this is
the way the winds blowing because
Twitter tells me so yeah so if Twitter
tells you that the police are
indiscriminately just killing black men
every night and the media buys into that
they woke the media start selling all
unarmed black men killed unarmed black
men kill and they'll never address the
hundreds and thousands of killings that
poor people and poor people color and
black people are doing to themselves
every day that never gets addressed
there's no Twitter feed that's popular
that's out there telling you who's
getting shot in Chicago every night
every weekend and so there's no hysteria
around that they created a hysteria
around when the police
make mistakes and or do something evil
which is very rare there's no trust
policemen don't want to go to jail not a
good experience inner policemen don't
want to be the targets of the vitriol
that goes along with killing anybody now
are there some bad cops absolutely but
what is our problem as african-americans
it's the gun violence we do to ourselves
that's what's taking us out and having a
real impact and that's what has our
communities living in fear I say this
all the time my dad was as black a human
being as you could possibly be he could
afford to live wherever he wanted he
built a new house in the ghetto because
he liked being around black people he
had a business that he ran in the ghetto
because he liked being with black people
when he puts alarms on his business when
he put bars on his business when he put
an alarm on his home when he carried a
38 every day that I knew him it wasn't
because of like Jason man these police
are out to get me they may break into my
home they may break into my break that
wasn't it yeah it was he was worried
about the people in his neighborhood and
the fear and again he again to God love
black people
yeah but the reality of what's going on
in our communities there's not a
pervasive fear the police there's a
pervasive fear of ourselves there's so
many interesting layers to that because
we I mean just ten minutes ago we were
discussing gun control now you're
describing how your dad had a 38 and it
wasn't yet he wasn't using it to stop
the government from go get him it was to
protect his own his own property and
Emily and all that stuff so so is it
just a gun issue so I've had a few
people on here that have talked about
how the policies often of the Democrats
have left the black community with these
sort of scraps that have sort of kept
them in that position do you do you
basically prescribe that I think that
yes I do
prescribe to that per to this far left
progressive ideology I think is a shell
game it's a trick it's a mirage
we tell you where for black people and
we again I wrote in the Wall Street
Journal this week about President
Clinton was an expert at making black
people feel he felt their pain and he
was an expert at creating policies that
intensified that pain and so President
Clinton loved us to death but instituted
and some mandatory minimum sentencing
policies some anti drug war policy are
some drug war policies that have
contributed greatly to mass
incarceration which is crippling black
people so is that the issue there that
when you talk about these progressive
policies that they all kind of sound
February it all sounds good we care
about black people we care about gay
people we care about Muslim people but
the policies themselves when you get
down to it are a lot more complex than
just saying we're for all these
communities which is really just some
pie-in-the-sky stuff yeah I think that
again take let's take black lives matter
and I was saying this in 2015 I was like
man this black lives matter thing sounds
so great
but it's poison and I would say the
admin I didn't know Trump was running
for president in 2015 or whatever but I
was like and atmosphere is being created
for a trump-like person to enter into
politics and benefit from black lives
matter and I say that because I have a
very dear friend in Kansas City who's
probably left of Bernie Sanders and he
and his wife adopted brought in their
home a half-black half-white child they
have two kids already they adopted a kid
who basically need you know they had no
place else to go so again I'm trying to
tell you what kind of people they are
and when the situation at the University
of Missouri with the kids protesting
mimicking the black lives matter out of
st. Louis
and they cost the president at that
school his job all based off of he
didn't say this or microaggressions or
whatever it is yeah
my friend hardcore University of
Missouri Fair was like whoa what are we
doing here what and he had I want to
pretty mother but he had questions about
black people and like hey well and I'm
telling you this guy loves everybody to
the left but the thing that happened in
Reverse in Missouri bothered him not to
the point that he would ever vote for
Trump but I was like whoa
if this bothered him oh my god what are
the people that are more moderate or
conservative what are they thinking
looking at this and they were thinking
okay y'all want to do this we're gonna
head to the ballot box and have a real
riot yeah you know I love the way you
frame that example because I think these
things are personal and they do come
down to those little moments and they
don't come down to the Twitter outrage
in the media outrage and everyone's
tuning out of CNN and all that stuff
because I would notice that too when I
talked I've talked a lot about the
college stuff yeah that and I get tons
of email people saying I'm a liberal but
what the hell is happening here what's
happening to my guy so when you make it
about that personal story that actually
resonates so I know certain amount of
people are gonna be watching this and
going wait a minute somehow he's Jason's
either selling out black people or or
he's not acknowledging racism and all
that which is it which is a perfect
segue to what got you in hot water last
week you were trending on Twitter which
is good I did you know you were trying
to do us all you were trying out Twitter
so you said something about LeBron James
and racism let's let's go there and see
we gave more undergoing more hot water
or let out where you're at I like how
are the turn of the so I listen I think
LeBron James is well-intentioned I think
a lot of what LeBron James does is
excellent I think his work in Akron with
poor people and the people of his
community there is awesome
I think that what I'm trying to
communicate to us as african-americans
is that we have to adopt strategies that
actually work in the long term and even
in the short term and wallowing in any
way in victimhood particularly over hurt
feelings or name-calling because again
it did he was called allegedly on his
gate the worst name in my book you can
be called yeah I get it
but at the end of the Dylan painted it
on the gate out there allegedly nigiri
rhymer it was removed before the police
got there by Leblon staff by 6:30 in the
morning they had repainted this fence
and the police were handed a picture of
her
okay I'm not questioning the sincerity
I'm just telling you the fact yeah some
people are actually questioning that but
that aside medicide uh so again all at
the end of the day that's hurt feelings
LeBron's feelings were heard his fan
there was no jeopardy it's a second home
they weren't there we don't even know
who the assailants were and so I'm
saying it as there was a time when our
victimhood was powerful and so you go
back to the 1960s 1950s when we were
denied the right to vote when we were
denied to go under schools when we were
denied where we could sit on a bus where
we couldn't sit in Stadium certainly
when there was Jim Crow segregation on
the books true victimhood didn't move
people like people would sit back and go
man that ain't right we got to fix that
that's unfair that's a human being and
we're denying them the same rights as
everyone else and so playing up our
victimhood at that point during the
Martin Luther King it was tremendous
strategy and it worked and it won us
right and so instead what I've seen ever
since the death of Martin Luther King
and Malcolm X is we as African Americans
first with and I'm not I don't want to
denigrate al Sharpton and Jesse Jackson
I just want to speak factually about
I actually know both of them have some
respect for both of them but they came
in and mimicked dr. King when dr. King
had won the battle for right and that's
all America promises you right America
does not promise you your feelings will
never be hurt America doesn't promise
you that people will never call you a
bad name
the world doesn't promise you that
America's Constitution promises you
right
they want us those right so our next
leaders and our next movement had to be
about how do we take advantage of these
rights we've won instead Jessie and I'll
and most of us of African Americans
we're still mimicking dr. King and that
movement and think there's some rewards
to be won by playing up our victimhood
and so to me what I would have wanted
LeBron James to say and that moment was
man this is terrible it's a bad
reflection on whoever the idiot is that
did there but trust me I'm going to be
fine
and as African American we need to
understand I'm so wealthy I can take
care of this there is some real
discrimination that goes on
mostly with poor people of color and
mostly with poor people that's where our
energies need to be focused the drug war
mass incarceration these issues have
real impact we can't be getting overly
emotional when some random white person
that we again do we think his wife yeah
I can't have that much control over our
happiness yeah do you think we just
simply ask too much of our athletes that
he this this thing happened you know go
if we go with the official story that
happened this thing happens we don't you
still don't know who did it but then the
media starts talking about it you know
you say what you say everyone on ESPN
says what they say and that fertile for
LeBron to do what you just asked him to
do it's like he's in the middle of the
finals right now they don't want all
these distractions and it's like he's
trying to you know steam down to oh as
we tape this you just try to figure that
out and yet we go to these people as if
they're guides that that are going to
solve all our problems great point and
it's another point I agree with in terms
of as I'm saying the leadership civil
rights leadership needed to change our
expectation for athletes needed to
change coming out of the 1960s
Muhammad Ali never had a corporation
like Nike handing him I had a billion
dollars over the course of time right if
you had put those puppet strings on
Muhammad Ali in the 1960s something
abisco or Pepsi or some tobacco company
put their hooks into Muhammad Ali for a
half billion dollars he would operate
completely differently and so our
expectations for athletes need to change
because this situation has changed
there's never going to be another
Muhammad Ali know how no way the
financial rewards and again I'm someone
Dave I know you're an atheist I grew up
in a small Baptist Church I'm a
spiritual person and believed in the
things taught in the Bible it's very
hard for a rich person no matter how
great they are to ever see the kingdom
of God and the point of that that's
Matthew nineteen twenty four the point
of that is probably a little suspicious
of the risk they have so many demands on
them that they really it's hard for them
to keep it real for the poor and people
that are really disadvantaged it's not
because they're horrible people
since the demands on them make it real
real hard and so LeBron James
Muhammad Ali did well but if the nation
in Islam was in his pocketbook the money
in the 1960s wasn't nearly what it is
now and he was denied the right to box
for three years so he was not a super
wealthy person he was basically mostly
in the same boat as the great mass of
African Americans LeBron James is not so
it's very hard for him to keep it 100%
authentic to that group of people and
get his heart can be there he can
remember what it was like for him when
he was poor
but at the end of the day the demands on
him are such he just can't be Muhammad
Ali what I think is most interesting
about that is you're not making a
judgment call on either one of them as
people know you're acknowledging the
reality yeah if you're not saying
Muhammad Ali would have acted this way
it's just a reality if someone has a
half a billion dollars coming to him
something's going to change something's
going to change doesn't mean you're
inherently evil or inherently good but
the ball has moved
I think LeBrons a great person I think
Muhammad Ali was a great person
I think LeBrons doing the best that he
can I think he is now surrounded by and
associated with some political people
and I don't trust political people he
when he started campaigning for Hillary
Clinton I like show me where my homily
campaign for anybody maybe he did but
certainly not in this prime I get ready
for more for ideas yeah and a candidate
or a party yeah and so what I saw that
ah and so when I saw his speech last
Wednesday I like man that smells like
Bill Clinton but that's nobody Bill
Clinton's that make them feel you make
them believe you feel their pain LeBron
that's the best thing you can do in this
moment and that's great brain
enhancement that's that's where all
these corporations right now want to be
that you know we're for equality but
don't look at the Vietnamese people
we're paying a penny to make these shoes
we're for equality just not in Vietnam
Yeah right tonight Nike makes the issues
that we all have yeah I just did Nike
IDs myself so I've got them or you know
a lot of these athletes will LeBron for
example right again I'm not judging
predict typically but you know huge heed
to the sprite guy he does all those
buyout marshals would heat with his
trainer ever tell him to drink sprite of
course not
look man yeah take all that high
fructose corn syrup that's good for you
Brian get a couple of those in you
before the big game
Dave I'm overweight we know what that
stuff does to all people but
particularly poor people and
particularly African Americans the soft
drink companies you know got us with
diabetes and high blood pressure and
everything else but yeah I'm not not
you will run make your money well but
don't parade around like your your
actions are about what's best for the
poor and again he may think that if I'm
LeBron James and I come out and say oh
we're all in the same boat and races in
my life is terrible because I'm black
here at America it's tough lady didn't
take care way too tough I'm like come on
man
your life is tough being an
african-american here to America with
all that money what with all that you
can do for your family and free most
people are struggling living paycheck to
paycheck LeBron James I'm not knocking
this is great his best friend maverick
Carter before the maverick Carter met
him Carter quit college at like 21 22
because LeBron made Nike give maverick a
job that paid him into six figures and
that's a dream life but that's not you
know I don't know where on the planet
he's going or where in the universe or
in the galaxy he's going where things
are going to be much better yeah do you
think that this specific issue of taking
athletes and then thinking that they
have to represent the whole community or
say everything perfectly or all that
that this is actually unique to the
black community cuz I've noticed
whenever a black athlete or former
athlete speaks out and says something
more in line of the way you were talking
so when Charles Barkley is there and
stuff about this or Stephen a Smith has
said some stuff about if anything that
sounds like it leaves a little to the
right they get attacked mercilessly I
mean I clicked your name when I saw the
trend I clicked it and there were there
were thousands of people calling for you
to be fired calling you all kinds of
words that I'm not going to say to your
face here I mean really terrible stuff
that for any of you guys that or you
know not just athlete to people that
talk about sports you do anything that's
a little bit out of that and the assault
is is pretty much it's a message to the
rest of the media and every other public
black public figure don't do because
mostly I'm uniquely I'm uniquely I don't
give an F
and so you know I told someone to try
poke Colin Cowherd this story the other
day about my family we said we'd have
family get-togethers at the holidays and
as a five six year old seven year old
kid I would be preaching to my family
about what I thought they were doing
along on what we were doing long and I
didn't care that it bothered people so I
don't care with people over Twitter say
about me but the overwhelming majority
of media members and celebrities they do
care who wants to be bombarded with all
that filth and to have people in didn't
sit there go all my bosses my my kids my
husband my wife my mom and dad may go to
my Twitter feed and see people saying
all this stuff about me I just better
stay away and be quiet
because I don't want to subject myself
or my family to that its silencing
people it's so people again what I keep
saying about Twitter has made media
celebrities and athletes we're all
politicians now and Twitter is our exit
polling and everything we say is is is
calculated say well how is this going to
land over Twitter am I going to get
crucified for this someone call me an
Uncle Tom or sellout and so people don't
say what they really think and then what
they do say is is meant to get retweeted
and loved over Twitter and the biggest
point I keep trying to make is from
Twitter to Instagram the snapchat to
Google to Facebook this is all coming
from San Francisco and Silicon Valley
and the values and sensibilities that
they have in San Francisco are being
pushed on the media and celebrities
through social media all right so I'm
glad you brought this up because the
first time we had communicated you
message me on on Twitter and send
something to this effect that the values
of the left and the Liberals have been
shifted from traditionally being in New
York they've shifted to San Fran
so can you explain that a little bit
well I think you people have been
talking about them the media chains and
it has changed
New York used to control the media
everybody wanted to work in New York
magazine newspaper TV you just make it
to New York and so everything all the
serious journalism rewards came out of
New Yorker you know that far east coast
and so the traditional New York
working-class labor liberal was
basically the values that were reflected
by the media
if certainly had a left-wing bias but to
me New York liberals are people that are
trying to perfect America hey Mary if we
just do this this will be better yeah so
this would be like maybe like a JFK
liberal or a daniel patrick moynihan
liberal without question yeah and I'll
say to my kind of little islands I'll
say this and people go ahead regards
well a Donald Trump like liberal oh well
I know we got our pro no doubt oh and so
what do you mean by now what do you
listen that gloss over that because I
know you hit on it earlier but but what
do I actually mean that if you really
look at what Donald Trump stands for he
he's more in line with JFK than Ronald
Reagan without question uh you know the
guy could carry a marriage
I don't he's he's a social liberal yeah
his his friends are diverse he he as
long as you willing to have a good time
Donald Trump's good with you yeah he
doesn't care
did you see that absurd fake outrage
when he had all those black business
leaders in the White House and Kellyanne
Conway I guess took the chatter took the
picture someone tell you after and her
foot on the couch and everyone made it
about that her being disrespectful to
the office meanwhile he's standing there
with a ton of black people who can have
tremendous and do have tremendous
influence to change things and somehow
that's the part that we forget about
we're set about Kellyanne Conway's foot
so
my point yeah New York media was in
control of everything everyone catered
their perspective point of view to some
degree to please new york because
everybody wants to make it New York and
make it there the advent of social media
and the importance of going viral of
being retweeted in light of executives
basing their decisions on how many
Twitter followers do you have
we it's become a popularity contest and
whoever has the biggest following is the
greatest thing in the media and once
people figured out oh man I can rig
Twitter I can buy followers I can buy
retweet I can say certain things because
again when you talk about Google
Facebook Instagram Twitter the employee
base is all coming from San Francisco
and to me San Francisco is a different
kind of liberal it's a revolutionary
liberal the Black Panther Party is is
from there it's a liberal there's like
not you know what America ain't right we
need to start all over from scratch and
I'm just not someone that wants to start
all over from scratch I'd I'm not
someone who buys the narrative that
America is so bad and so evil that it
must be scrapped and started all over
again
America is incredibly flawed like
everybody else on the planet and America
has made really horrible mistakes but
America is also done in my view more
good than just about everybody else and
America again overcame slavery and
overcame Jim Crow to the point that
Oprah could do what she did President
Obama could do what he did
Muhammad Ali could do what he did I can
do the little bit that I'm doing and
again it was an ugly fight but we won
some rights and
creating some opportunities so I'm not
for blowing up America I'm for uh you
know perfecting and still trying to
improve America yeah well I always love
talking to someone from a different walk
of life that I agree with so much on a
philosophical level that we there's a
lot of bad stuff here of course yes
there's a lot of good stuff and if we
can if the opportunity is equal then
that's what true equality is and that's
and that's what we have to always work
for but we've got more here than pretty
much anywhere else well look and we're
dealing with more diversity than just
about anybody else this is really the
melting pot and so people are oh my god
you know there's racism here but well of
course there is because we have more
people and again I say this all the time
I'm not defending racism I'm
acknowledging it and acknowledging the
fact that throughout the world's history
it's never not been here it's not going
away people's minds will not be
perfected on this planet and so we can't
control what everyone thinks and it's
foolish to try to control and to think
that every white person whoever it was
that did this vandalism and LeBrons how
e we're probably not going to fix that
person and it's okay in a way is that
the real function of success of a
movement that the arc has bent to
justice so that we now look at little
things and blow them out of proportion
so again just as you're saying you're
not defending what the guy broke on the
bronze gate of course not but that is
nothing compared to being hung up by a
tree or any we're not having being able
to use the same water found right so
it's a function of success you can't
make everything disappear but but here's
where I think things get dangerous and
because I want to be clear as people run
away or whip out so I'm here celebrating
Trump I really believe that this
irresponsible way that we talk about
race is why we have a reality TV star
sitting in the white house and that's
dangerous
we shouldn't the world's most powerful
country shouldn't have a reality TV star
who's unqualified sitting in the White
House but because of the way we have
mishandled the racial discussion in
America it's created an opportunity for
someone like Donald Trump in my view so
I'm with you that the trends of all of
this are born out of what's happening
online I've done a couple videos about
it and I even get caught in it just this
past weekend on Friday I tweeted I'm
getting off the grid and I say I put a
little matrix picture up I said I'm off
the grid then I think it was Saturday
the the London attacks happened and I
and I heard about it obviously just from
clicking the TV and from friends or
whatever and I immediately had this
feeling I had to get back on there and
say something or I had to share my
thoughts or something and I didn't do it
and I fought every every impulse do it
because I really I'm one guy some people
look to me for some information but if I
can't just sit one out that that is a
huge problem for us personally so we all
have the personal burden of this too in
a weird way I say without question what
I've done to my Twitter feed is like if
you don't have a registered phone number
or email you just don't see your tweets
I don't say you can tweet at me but I
just don't see you yeah and I'm trying
to only you feel that need though that
need to disconnect yes well now is it
need to disconnect but the need to
comment so something happens and then
you know certain many people are going
to look to you yes you know even though
you're a sports guy they're going to
look to you and go what what happened do
you feel that need I feel it but here's
the what I've tried to set up is my
precedent of it you know it's maybe a
futile attempt but I'm my model with
Twitter has always been judge my columns
enjoy my tweets yeah and sometimes they
don't even take this ships here it's
really not now when I go sit down to
write a column yeah that's what I really
believe Twitter is what people think and
there is a huge disconnect between what
we think and
we believe yeah I think I'm the
best-looking man on the planet I think
that Halle Berry should be beating down
my doors except to date me do I really
believe that not really and so we all
think stupid things I mean anyway we all
inappropriate things we think racist
things but do we believe them a lot your
thoughts help develop what you believe
but you know a lot of the things we
think are we know are inappropriate we
know have no merit and but everyone
reacts to Twitter like it's someone's
belief and it's just not so as a guy
that's on cable television but you
obviously intimately get internet
culture what do you make of television
in general right now like not not only
on the sports side well let's talk about
a fourth side first like you know
there's huge problems at ESPN they're
there I mean they just fired what like
500 people a ton of on-air people guys
have religions there for 2035 100 people
100 on-air people right I think maybe
yeah previously the year before they
dumped three four hundred people but
here recently it's been about a hundred
but yeah so they're having major
problems people are cutting the cord and
we know all that stuff you're on Fox
Sports that a different situation over
there but how does that feel for you to
be in a in a industry that is just going
under so much chain and yet at the same
time you understand the other culture
that's killing it I think that and I've
written this in the Wall Street Journal
that ESPN and other media outlets have
been so consumed with politics that they
forgot how to do business I agree and so
and they've been so focused on the
political construct rather than
innovation and how do we keep our
business healthy and I feel horrible for
the people that are paying the price for
this mistake because if a business
because the essence of business it's not
a political machine
and the first thing a business has to do
is take care of its employees and make
sure they have a place to work and and
they have abandoned that by thinking
that progressive ideology is a sound
business move and it's just a political
agenda it's not a business move yeah and
if anything it might be a business move
that's the opposite of what their
audience wants the reverse business move
actually I think without question
because we get remove politics from it
Sports is a conservative culture it's a
coaches come in from literally go on any
problem we got it solved in this locker
room no excuses I don't care what
outsiders are doing the referee makes a
bad call we move on yeah we control our
destiny we don't hear what color you are
with your sexuality data can you play
yes it's a meritocracy yeah and when you
start injecting all of these far left
progressive conversations on to a group
of people at home and this is
inconsistent with what I've been taught
in sports this isn't what I expected and
so whether people like it or not it's
easier more appropriate and better
business to talk sports from a
conservative perspective than it is from
a progressive perspective it's just
that's just factual you know it's so
funny to me because when I was in
college I really wanted to be a sports
center anchor that's what I wanted to be
and I went to college in the in the mid
90s when it was to me the heyday of
sports center when Kilbourne was over
there who was the first one to me that
made it funny to which I thought was
also and it was the heyday of Dan
Patrick and Olbermann who have both gone
very political in different directions
these days so it's funny for me to be
sitting across from someone that's
that's in that world that so
acknowledges how haywire it's gotten
because Sports Center used to be fun and
funny and now when I click on their so
it's always political and that has
nothing to do with why you watch sports
is the escape not not the vehicle for
more it is not
and again when I people hear this and
say well Whitlock is because I am I am
for talking about Colin Kaepernick got
from a traditional sports perspective
and so Colin Kaepernick kneels down and
protests the flag and police brutality
and I'm like hey man first of all this
is bad business if you are if you cut
these kids young people are even taught
the business that they've entered into
sports let's say you're a football
player you get to actually go study
football in college
you would be understand like no no the
reason why you make so much money is
because people Zell in the television
networks decided to attach football to
patriotism and the military that's the
way the game is sold john wa cinders
voice all the highlights have been
packaged up all the respect for the
military and the flag they wanted sports
fans to feel like the most american
thing you can do besides join of the
military is sit on your ass and watch
football that's America that's why Colin
Kaepernick made 14 million dollars
because they were selling that and it
looks good he just did some bad business
but well I'm making money because the
people here believe they're supporting
America and they love it and his
patriotism and I'm going to choose this
place to kneel down and protest America
and its brutality it's wrong and go to
the police headquarters and do that I'm
not against them protesting yeah do it
at police headquarters when you do it on
a football field
where all the television networks and
the NFL are all in on we're selling
patriotism here it's bad business is
stupid so you're dealing with it just a
purely realest level a former somewhat
colleague of mine did a video kind of
bashing you about this and it's like
you're just dealing with the you're just
dealing with reality the reality that if
people stop buying tickets if people
stop buying jerseys all of these things
well eventually you might get cut you
might not get the contract and not
everything takes place
in between those lines look when
footballs a TV show and so if James
Gandolfini in The Sopranos decided I'm a
glob script I'm going to become a
religious figure on this show I'm not
going to be a mafia came here they would
have fired him and got someone else
right because it's a TV show yeah this
this is the role we wants you to play in
the NFL this is how we make money this
is how we do our TV show he's not
playing his role and and all the lunatic
people oh my god what he did was so
courageous and this is none of them are
going to put 14 million dollars in Colin
Kaepernick's pocket not one of them yeah
and I've been the ones that might agree
with him politically or yeah he was what
he's fighting for
yes and so now here he is begging
forward to get back in MFL leaking out I
won't take a knee anymore he's having to
back off of the stands he took and again
look how preposterous it is I'm not
gonna in the protest till things improve
for the better
Donald Trump elected president well
things have improved I'm not I'm not
gonna protest anymore so is it so it's
like sort of the perfect storm because
it's like you know you know it's the
idea of fighting against racism you're
fighting against capitalism you're
fighting is the patriarchy you're
fighting against all these sort of ideas
that they put out there yeah and at the
same time it makes your victimhood thing
go off the chart so it's a perfect storm
it is and again people think I hate
Colin Kaepernick because I've been so
critical I'm just disappointed I
understand what he was trying to
accomplish Colin Kaepernick whether
people want to address it or not or deal
with it they think I'm terrible for
going here but it's just factual he's
got an identity issue he's half black
half white both of his parents never
knew his dad his mom gave him up for
adoption he's raised by a suburban white
family and Milwaukee I don't care who
you are that's going to create some ooh
in this American
Erica that's so racially divided over
social media that's going to create some
identity issues for you and Colin
Kaepernick's reputation before the
protest was horrible with his teammates
he was awkward didn't get along with
every people and then once he did this
thing now he's one of the blackest guys
in the history of America all everybody
across the league loves him and so he's
loving it I get it
but his bad gives us for him he would be
better off continuing to create wealth
who played in the NFL and using that
wealth to effect real change for the
people he says he's concerned about so
maybe opening a school or an
after-school program or whatever it is a
lot of jail enrolls he's a former
athlete or NBA player it's got the Jalen
Rose Leadership Academy in Detroit it's
tremendous
again many things LeBron is doing in
Akron tremendous that's again when I the
Muhammad Ali model is done it's over
it's not the 1960s anymore there's too
much money be made and it's not the
right role for athletes they're not
political spokesman Colin Kaepernick
won't even come out and talk anymore
because there's not enough substance for
him to hold a press conference and say
anything everything's all controlled or
he's retweeting what people were saying
about him and trying to speak for
himself that way he's not he's way out
overseas we're just way out overseas
it's so interesting because it brings up
so many things about speech and
capitalism and democracy and the way we
deal with race and all that stuff to
circle back a little bit though do you
remember the moment when you realized
that the sports business was being
corrupted by this leftist stuff because
I can think of a couple moments but I'll
give you a chance first before I tell
you mine well a lot of people point to
the Caitlyn Jenner thing that's what I
was going to say and it that way that
was the end of it that was where I saw
like the full-on like because to give
her the SB again I'm trans friends I'm
totally you know for the trans community
want them to be treated equally and with
respect and all that stuff but he became
so obviously politicized that what was
it the athlete of the year the oil time
achievement award or courage Awards I
over a young woman that was dying a
cancer the continued to play basketball
yeah it was just like this is just silly
more than anything else that wasn't my
moment I because what I was and I was
because I really have some respect for
ESPN and the people of it running but
I'll just say it because it occurred I
was inside the belly of the beast you
know and so I saw it more acutely in
terms of what I was dealing with my
second go-around at ESPN and and what I
saw it again I'm not demonizing anybody
see a massive corporation that is backed
by Disney another massive corporation
right and massive corporations in this
era are a lot like Congress they're a
lot like watch it's a lot like having
something in DC politics there are so
many special interest groups within a
massive corporation ESPN has something
called pulse people United to serve and
leave in Excel it's it's their black
employees group they got something
called pride people respectful
individual diversity excellent society
it's their gay a special interest group
they have a couple other special
interest groups and again when you have
special interest groups
it makes decisions very compromises that
ESPN is in a startup business that gets
ignored virtually every rule and just do
what's right and we'll deal yes p.m. is
an environment and most major
corporations are human resource
departments are all powerful
if you've gathered up some special
interest groups they have a lot of
powerful and it's hard to make the
absolute best decision in that
environment and so I saw that firsthand
how the specialist
the human resources department had so
much influence over what took place that
is why all this organizations handcuffed
it it can't just do the right thing for
its customer base they've got all these
agendas at work that put any leader of a
self spot yeah and ironically it's those
agendas as we've been talking about that
it's sort of led to the destruction of
the actual business yes which is a crazy
position so you're at Fox now and you
know I talked about the mainstream media
all the time and all that and I think
there's an idea out there that somehow
when you work at a big corporation that
they're telling you everything to say
and all that and I don't suspect they
are telling you what to say at all but
do you find for yourself just to protect
as you talk about your own rational
self-interest as a businessman and
someone that's quite near stuff out
there do you and Colin ever sit down and
before you do a show and say well maybe
we shouldn't hit this in this way or me
or maybe I'm going to go further than
you want to go this way or any of that
kind of stuff we have a lot of
discussions of collaring and I look race
is an area I've been operating in as a
media person for my entire career
it's what I'm passionate about I have a
lot more time to think about these
issues than most people it's my area of
expertise it's not Colin's area of
expertise uh and so we do talk about
that beforehand and you know had long
discussions about hey Colin you know I'm
going to make sure I don't put you in a
bad place or some dangerous place that
gets some you get you involved in some
kind of full-out raid situation or
whatever but we pretty much talk about
what we want to talk about and Colin's
pretty fearless uh and so it is funny
though I I hear all the time from people
all you're just saying what Fox wants
you to say right that's why I'm African
yeah ed I was like hey well I don't
think you understand the current media
culture and the the pressures on
executive
is and people running networks now uh
you know if if I'm an executive I'll
speak hypothetically I want to stay in
very safe places ok so if I feel any
pressure that would be the pressure I
know I'm getting zero pressure to be an
outspoken person who goes against the
grain against what Twitter thinks is
popular about race
no one is know if anything I get the
exact opposite yeah preach to the choir
but isn't that so there's these very
strong competing forces then because if
you want not if you just want the clicks
but if the clicks just exist you say
what you think right now the clicks
exist because you're saying stuff that's
outside of the the mainstream now you've
got maybe executives that just want to
keep everything under control but at the
same time they love that conversation
like they hate it in a way because they
don't want the heat to come on to them
or cause any problems for them but so
the heat works both ways here I would
say David though if you look at where
the clicks are the clicks aren't in my
perspective the question if you go the
way again you gotta remember Silicon
Valley and San Francisco are controlling
the clicks and who gets clicks the
clicks are in the far left perspective
if you know if you really study who's it
let's go back two years before Fox News
but got involved in all the controversy
or whatever based on Twitter and social
media you would think that Chris Hayes
had a ten times bigger audience than
Bill O'Reilly right up based on social
media and so the clicks are in you know
saying that the police are out here
randomly killing black people and
America is completely rigged against the
black man you have no chance that's
where all the clicks are yeah well
that's funny you mention that because I
think it's so interesting now the foxes
Fox News is struggling that there's such
a feeding frenzy around it Fox was
crushing everybody but you're right if
you were to just look at retweets
obviously Chris is doing a lot better
than them Bill O'Reilly he's a count
was more of like just a corporate
controlled account so you'd think that
their ratings would have been much
better but now there's such a feeding
frenzy because they see there's blood in
the water around Fox and Friends ease
around 12 what anybody can give ratings
talk about Trump yeah and but you know
I've often said and I stand by this if
you build any type of media content
based around pleasing Twitter you're
building something that's going to fail
that you're going to get all kinds of
clicks when we put real people just
start paying attention to that I know it
I started saying this when the sharknado
TV show or movie way back think they
might UFO and all over Twitter and then
the radiance came out and no one lost
and and I don't want to say this to be
disrespectful I'm not trying to start
anything but someone will see this and I
think I'm just picking on but I wrote a
piece after Melissa harris-perry show on
MSNBC got cancelled mm-hmm and and I was
just like the show was completely built
for social media and it never raided no
one ever was and uh it's a mistake and
and I get we all are media so obsessed
with social media and we think that's
reality and I just keep trying to preach
people know man it's not remotely
reality it's not what American things if
you follow social media you thought
Trump was going to lose the election if
you believed in what you were seeing
social media yeah and it's just a false
indicator yeah all right so so one more
for you that I think will sort of tie
this all together at the top of the show
I mentioned and you know I talked about
free speech a lot and just in the last
week alone there was the Kathy Griffin
thing there was the Bill Maher thing I
don't know if you're following this
story about Brett Weinstein the
professor up at Evergreen State who
gotten a lot of trouble over over not
being racist so they're of course
they're calling him as its point being
there's a lot of stuff around free
speech then you got into hot water about
about LeBron and the gate and all that
what do you think of just sort of the
general state of free speech because
I've tried to explain to people these
aren't First Amendment issues this is
none of these things have anything to do
with the government but but the chill
factor that you started talking about
way back when that this is real and not
not everybody is as brave as you where
you you wash this stuff off but which is
the average person how serious do you
think this is III think it's very
serious I think that I think it's as a
media person I think it's the biggest
issue going again there are clearly
bigger issues of the climate there's you
know all kinds of issues going on but
for me as a media person the silencing
of original thought the silencing of
debate the fact that people that
disagree can't seem to find a way to
disagree respectfully and exchange ideas
that if you disagree with someone
they're evil and they must be destroyed
that's really troubling to me we're
creating a society that will go to a
really dangerous place and get we keep
calling Trump the fascists and I don't
see the evidence of that I see those of
us in the media where the fascist who
everyone's trying to silence people and
trying to create a belief that someone
we disagree with is better off dead than
allowing them a platform yeah well I
love finding allies in this space and
it's very obvious to me that you're one
and we need more I mean that's what I
tell my audience all the time we just
some guy to created a YouTube channel
you're some guy that is passionate about
sports and started writing about it and
now people care and that's that's what
we need more of because we're just two
guys say what we think you know in the
we need to I need to what I felt and the
why was attracted to your work what
you're doing to it I gotta support
people that are real and regardless of
color regardless of religion
regardless of sexual orientation uh if
you're real I just got to support you uh
because it's just critically critically
important because the other side has all
gathered up because I believe a lot of
things are orchestrated I get you know
you've even missed the or we didn't talk
about you know I got attacked because I
defended someone that got in a argument
with levar ball the Lonzo balls dead and
and Charlamagne tha God who hosts a
popular urban hip-hop show in New York
made some Emmett Till analogy to
Kristine Leahy who I work with it so how
she's doing
and so and then LeBron James comes back
two weeks later or ten days later
talking about Emmett Till and I don't
have any proof of but I'm just like this
feels orchestrated who who
Kristine Leahy has a dispute with levar
ball and somehow it has something to do
with Emmitt too and and LaVon Ron's gate
gets vandalized and somehow its Emmett
Till and so these talking points are
being passed around and it's
orchestrated to me I do agree and you
know I always quote Carl Sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so it's like you
don't have absolute to that but it's
always sort of like the fake news meme
the day after the election everybody
started talking about all the mainstream
and saying everything is fake news
because they sort of lost control of the
narrative
yes so I have no evidence that there was
a newsletter going around to the heads
of CNN and MSNBC but if you are thinking
person you at least have to explore that
that situation to figure out what we're
up against I don't think there's any
question that there's an orchestrated
movement look I I felt like what did
spin from the Galka Network they bullied
the hell out of ESPN for years and I
think smart people I ottoman worldwide
leader in sports sports culture is
conservative let's let's go take on the
head of the snake ESPN and push them our
direction and it worked
I hit work yeah I believe that's been
pushed bullied ESPM into becoming
progressive yeah and I don't think it's
an accident because you know once their
job was done they started writing
celebratory pieces about how great ESPN
is yeah I suspect we're going to do this
again I hope so for more on Jason you
can watch him on speak for yourself on
foxsports1
and send all your hate tweets directly
to a cop with life Jason not ask Jason
when I asked without you
[Music]
you